- Welcome to the Lifespan Podcast.
Where we discuss the science of aging
and how to be healthier
at any stage of life.
I'm David Sinclair.
I'm a professor of Genetics
at Harvard Medical School,
and co-director of the Paul F. Glen Center
for Biology of Aging Research.
This series of podcasts
is about why we age
and things we can do to slow, stop,
and even reverse that process.
Last episode,
we talked about really
cutting-edge science
and procedures that
people are currently doing
with their doctors
and what they might be
doing in the coming years.
But today, we're going to
talk about what you can do
to slow, stop,
and even reverse the aging
of the outside of your body.
And I'm joined today by my
lovely co-author and co-presenter
- Co-human.
Co-ed.
No.
- Conspirator?
- Co-conspirator.
Matthew LaPlante.
Welcome.
- Hey.
All right, let's do this again.
You know this.
I was not so excited about this episode.
When you told me,
when Wonderboy Rob told us
that it was going to be
about cosmetic aging.
I poo-pooed this, then we prepped for it.
We've been having great conversations
over the last few days.
I'm actually really excited
about this conversation.
- That's true. Especially the parts about
improving your sexual function.
I thought you were excited about the most.
- That's not in this episode.
We'll have an episode on that.
No, today we're talking
about cosmetic aging,
and we're talking about the difference
between interventions that
are only aimed at appearance
and interventions that might impact
both appearance and aging.
- And we had to cover a number of topics,
including how to keep your hair,
skin and nail looking young
and even reversing
aspects of that process.
- And we should say here,
there's nothing wrong with
things that are purely aesthetic
that only work to make
ourselves look good.
Because those things might not
impact our biological aging,
but they can affect us
socially, emotionally, mentally,
like it will make our lives better.
So we're not going to poo-poo.
I've used the word
poo-poo now several times.
So we're not going to denigrate
interventions that are
only aimed at appearances,
but we are going to talk more about
and center our focus around interventions
that might also have an anti-aging effect.
- Exactly. And there are coverups.
We're going to to talk
a little bit about Botox
and other creams.
But really I think what's most exciting
and most powerful
are the technologies that are
available now and shortly,
that can boost the body's
ability to fight aging
and even reverse it.
We put them into a couple of buckets.
We've talked about this
in previous episodes.
Is the adversity mimetics which we love.
Which is really slowing
down aging and reversing it.
Or the abundance mimetics that
give you a short term gain,
make you look good,
but long term may not work or
even have deleterious effects.
- Now this is usually
the part in the podcast
where I say, "Hey, David, we
have to thank our sponsors."
But actually there's
something else we need to do
because there was something
we neglected to talk about
in our last episode.
Well, it was a pretty glaring
oversight on our part.
- Well, we focused a lot on testosterone,
which is used by men
and women increasingly,
but we neglected to
talk about other hormone
that are not found much in men.
Estrogen, progesterone,
and this pertains to
menopause hormonal therapy
and overall hormone
replacement therapy for women.
So let's talk about that.
- Yeah.
And one of the reasons why this is really
both interesting and important
is because menopause effects
the first part of our body,
the first organ in a woman's body
to really experience the
effects of biological aging.
- Right. Sometimes even
in women's twenties,
but late thirties, early
forties, this can occur.
- So this is often before your
heart starts to show damage,
your lung starts to
show damage from aging,
your brain, even.
- Yeah. And there are ways
of making sure that you
go through that transition
if you're a woman.
In a more natural way.
And so we actually called
up a friend of mine,
Cindy Meston, who's a professor in Austin
who has given us some really good advice.
Given that you and I are men,
we typically don't know a lot about this.
- And should not lecture on it.
- No, we're not lecturing,
but we will talk about
how it pertains to aging.
What the current thought
about HRT actually is.
- Well, can you take us through,
we had this conversation several years ago
and it stuck with me
for a really long time.
Can you talk about why it is
that the female reproductive
system ages earlier
than the rest of the body?
You started to notice this in mice
- Yeah. In fact, that's one of the reasons
we studied fertility in mice
because we could get those
experiments done more quickly.
And we discovered,
and we'll bring this
up in a later episode,
that we can reverse female infertility
with molecules that stimulate.
These were two ones that we work on.
But today we're going to talk
about the late part of life
about how to replace those hormones.
The reason you need to do that
is that we've evolved as a species
to have children up until
the age of about 30.
And then we should stop. Why?
Because having kids as a
woman is very dangerous.
There was a time when,
I think there was a 1 in 5 chance
you would die from childbirth.
- You needed to be
younger or more vigorous
to just get through that process.
- Right.
And then you have to put a lot of effort
into raising those kids.
It's not like an insect
where you just let them
blow away in the wind.
You have to spend at least a decade.
And these days, two
decades, raising those kids.
And if you keep doing
that your whole life,
it might take away from the energy
that you put into the ones that you have.
So for that reason,
women have evolved to become
infertile around the age of 40.
- And that process that they
go through is menopause.
For some women it's brutal.
- For sure. There's the well known things.
There's mood swings, vaginal dryness,
loss of sex drive, migraines,
hot flashes, of course.
There's also really
serious effects on health,
including increased
susceptibility to heart disease.
So this is clearly something
that needs to be addressed.
And there are increasingly better ways
to be able to allow women
to not just transition through menopause,
but to continue having
the right hormone levels
to protect them against aging long-term.
- And one of these things is
menopausal hormone therapy,
which is chiefly and has
been traditionally chiefly
estrogen replacement.
Although increasingly other
hormones are explored.
And this is a treatment
that can offer people
a lot of symptomatic relief.
There were concerns for a really long time
that it had some pretty
gnarly side effects itself,
and even some could do
some long term damage.
We're learning more about
that right now, though.
- Estrogen used to be used primarily.
And now, what we're finding
is that the dual use of
estrogen and progesterone
in the right combination
and ratio and timing
is really important.
And it may be that some
of these side effects
that people have been worried about
and studies that came out early,
particularly in the early 2000s
about the increased risk of cancer
are largely due to,
I wouldn't say the misuse,
but the lack of understanding
of what the natural
levels are for a woman.
In fact, most women don't know
what their baseline levels are
in their thirties and forties.
That's why Cindy actually,
Professor Meston, recommended to us
that women should get
their baseline levels
and measure during certain
phases of their menstrual cycle,
particularly in the luteal phase,
what the levels are of
estrogen and progesterone
in their thirties and forties,
so that when they reach
their late forties, fifties,
their physician can match those
and continue the on at those
natural levels for them.
- And this continues a
common theme that we've had
in I think almost every
discussion we've had
so far in this series,
which is unless you're monitoring,
unless you're tracking,
you have no way of knowing what
your actual health state is.
- Right. And so I've
been using InsideTracker,
one of our sponsors.
You can use a doctor if you want.
But that's true not just for
estrogen and progesterone,
but for testosterone.
Men and women typically
don't measure their levels.
They should be.
And there's a sex hormone
binding globulin called SHBG,
which is important
for binding all these proteins
in the blood, these hormones.
And if you don't measure that one as well,
you're flying blind with your dashboard.
So I would recommend
measuring that as well.
And if the levels of that become too high,
SHBG it's called,
then that can actually
counteract these therapies.
- Okay. And so, again,
at the risk of lecturing on things
like body parts that we don't have,
suffice it to say a lot of the things
that people have been hearing
about menopausal hormone
therapy for many years,
the dangers of it
shouldn't scare people off
from having conversations
with their physicians
about this potential treatment.
- Exactly.
And even increasingly so as physicians
and researchers like Cindy,
are figuring out the
right ratio and timing
of these hormones.
Increasingly, it's looking
like there's a real long-term protection.
So not just during the years of menopause,
but extending that hormone
replacement therapy
out for decades
seems to protect against
the heart disease problems
and bone loss.
But of course, there are some downsides,
particularly if you have a
history of breast cancer.
You don't want to be pumping
yourself with estrogen.
So please do talk to your
physician about that.
- We mentioned a list
of effects that happened
during menopause earlier.
One of the ones that we didn't mention
that relates to the theme of this episode
is epidermal thinning.
- Right. This is what happens
to your skin as you get older
and it's accelerated rapidly
during and especially after menopause.
- And we're going to talk
about that more in a moment,
but first, let's do thank our sponsors.
- We definitely need to do that.
Cause they make this episode
and all the others freely available.
Our first sponsor is Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens is an
all-in-one daily green drink
that supports better health
and peak performance.
It's developed from a complex blend
of 75 vitamins, minerals,
and whole foods sourced ingredients.
It's filled with adaptogens for recovery,
probiotics, prebiotics,
and digestive enzymes for gut health,
along with vitamin C and zinc
citrate for immune support.
I've been drinking Athletic
Greens for a number of years now
as a way to cover all
my nutritional bases.
I'm often traveling
and sometimes my diet just isn't the best.
So by drinking Athletic Greens,
I know I'm getting the
vitamins and minerals
that I need to stay healthy.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim a special offer.
They're giving away five free travel packs
plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 for immune support
and vitamin K2, which keeps the
calcium out of your arteries
and puts it in your bones.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
to claim this special offer.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by Levels.
Levels is an app
that syncs with a
continuous glucose monitor
which they provide,
and it interprets your
glucose data for you.
I was so impressed by Levels
that I recently joined them as an advisor.
By monitoring your blood glucose levels,
Levels allows you to see how
different foods impact you.
I've had fun running tests of my own,
seeing how different foods
impact my blood sugar levels.
For example,
I've learned that white rice
really spikes my blood sugar,
whereas potatoes don't.
And as we've discussed on this podcast,
having stable blood glucose
is really important.
Not only for daily mental
and physical energy,
but also for long-term health.
So if you would like to try Levels,
you can skip the 150,000 person waitlist
and join today.
You can go to levels.link/sinclair
and claim the special offer.
That's levels.link/sinclair
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from
your blood and your DNA
to help you better understand your body
and reach your health goals.
I've been using InsideTracker
for over a decade.
And I'm the chair of their
scientific advisory board.
The reason I've long used inside tracker
is because they provide the
best blood and DNA analysis
that I'm aware of.
They make it easy to get your blood drawn.
You can either go to a nearby clinic,
or like I do, have
someone come to your home.
It's super easy.
From there, InsideTracker
presents your blood analysis
in an easy to understand way
and they give diet and
lifestyle recommendations
to improve your blood biomarkers
essentially to optimize your body.
Another feature that InsideTracker has
is their InnerAge Test,
which I helped develop.
This test shows you what
your biological age is,
how it connects to your chronological age,
and what you can do to improve it.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you should go and visit
insidetracker.com/sinclair
and get a 25% discount
of any of their plans.
So use the code Sinclair at the checkout
on the insidetracker.com website.
- Okay, let's get into this.
A lot of people, I think, know this.
This fact, but it still, I think,
surprises some people.
The largest organ in the human body is
- The skin.
- And it's sizable.
- Well, it's 1/6 of
your total body weight,
which is massive.
And it's the barrier to the world.
And the health of your
skin is super important
for the health of the rest
of your body and vice versa.
- And monitoring the health of your skin
can give you a lot of insights
into the health of your body.
When we were talking before,
I likened this to going
to the grocery store
and looking at a piece of fruit.
- Right. If you see some bruises
and some damage on there,
you can assume that it
wasn't handled very well,
but also it might be old.
So you give it a squeeze,
you see how it is.
And we'll talk about ways to
do that with our own bodies
to really have a quick test
and even some molecular tests
to determine how molecularly
old we actually are.
- There's one you've been
doing all morning this morning.
Do you want to do it now?
- The skin pinch test.
- Yeah.
- Sure.
So what you do is you
rest your hand on a table,
so it'd be relaxed normally.
And then you grab the back of your skin,
pinch it up,
and it should, if you're young,
pop straight down in less than 2 seconds.
Someone in their thirties and forties,
it'll pop straight down. But
once you get into your fifties,
it's going to take many seconds.
- And the chart that you found
and I don't know what the
scientific basis for this is,
but the chart that you found said
when you get into your
like eighties and nineties,
it can take, well, like 20, 30 seconds?
Something like that.
- Oh. Even worse.
So for people like us,
were in our forties and fifties,
should be less than 10 seconds.
By the time you're 60,
it typically takes 10 to
15 seconds to come down.
Over 70, between half and
a whole minute to go down.
- Okay. And you're 50 and
yours went down right away.
So that's good.
- Well, I've been doing the right stuff
for a number of years,
but that's pretty good for
someone my age, looks like yours
- We'll also going to
fix that on the video.
Yeah.
It also helps if you tense your hands.
- We don't probably even need to say this,
but like, it's just obvious.
I am aging faster than you are aging,
but I'm doing okay on
the the skin popup test.
- You are.
There are other ones we
can talk about later,
like nail growth.
- Let' stick on skin for
a minute here though.
Because one of the things we talked about
right before the sponsorship
break was epidermal thinning.
This is a problem for women who
are suffering from menopause
It's also a problem for men.
It's a problem for people as they age.
And I think a lot of
people don't understand
or don't really think about it,
at least, I didn't think about
why this is such a pernicious problem.
Why is it bad if we have really thin skin?
In addition to the fact that
we can't take insults well.
- Right.
Well, we tend to forget
that our skin is the
major organ in our body
to protect us from death.
You know, we've seen with COVID-19
what happens is once you
get a pathogen in there,
it'll run rampant.
And so our skin is the main barrier.
And as we get older, it can
be damaged much more easily.
You see an elderly people,
the bruising, the ripping, the tearing.
It's becoming paper thin.
And so we need to protect it.
It's not just about looking good
in your forties, fifties, sixties,
but in your seventies,
eighties and nineties,
it's super important.
It's life and death
as to how young your skin still is.
- This really hit home for me
when I met David Armstrong.
- Yeah. So he's the US's top surgeon
for ulcers, wounds in the foot.
And he spends his whole life
trying to figure out ways to
reduce the number of ulcers,
which is about 13% of the US
has a foot ulcer right now
that's about
- Like right now.
- 40 million Americans have foot ulcers.
- Yeah.
- And we don't talk about it.
Cause these are people
who typically are older
and don't have a voice
in society, typically.
But he is on a mission
to advocate for the cure of these things.
And also he spends his life
trying to cure people of these ulcers.
But it's very difficult.
The reason is these ulcers,
because the skin is old,
it doesn't heal very well.
And typically it'll be open.
A weeping wound and
crusty around the outside.
It looks like you've
got a quarter size hole
in the bottom of your foot.
That just arises just by
tripping on something,
or stepping on a something
sharp that's layering it out.
- But if it's coupled diabetes,
which leads to a loss of sensation,
of feeling in the foot,
this can be incredibly dangerous
and lead to among other
things, amputation.
Infection, which leads
back to this whole reason
why we're talking about
why it's so important
to keep our skin as thick
and healthy as possible.
- And keep the feeling in our skin.
Remember, our nerves are all in our skin.
And as you get older,
you lose that feeling.
And there's a story
that we wrote about in our book, Lifespan,
where one of David Armstrong's patients
had stepped on a thumbtack, a little nail,
and it was in his foot, he didn't notice.
And he only noticed days later
because he could hear a tapping
sound as he was walking.
- It's absolutely terrible.
Every time I hear that
story, I just cringe.
- Well, it's a really big problem
because often you can't make these heal.
And then what David does
and all these other surgeons
is to cut around that scabby site.
And it just gets bigger
and bigger and bigger.
And eventually you've
just got this open wound.
Next thing you have to
do is cut the foot off.
And then you keep cutting and cutting.
I think after about five years
of getting one of these big ulcers,
you are almost certainly going to die.
It's worse than getting
a cancer diagnosis.
- And there's a lot of people
probably listening right now
and go, "Oh no, this is
never going to happen to me.
I don't have to worry about
that. I'm super healthy.
I'm not going to get diabetes."
But we're all aging.
And I think most people can
picture their elder self.
And when they do, they see their skin,
it's a little more wrinkly,
it's a little more saggy.
It's a little thinner.
And this actually means something
more than just appearances.
And we know this from this 2012 study,
where researchers took the photos
of about 300 elderly people
and they gave them to another
cohort of people to rate.
They rated for the age.
- Is that the Lothian
Birth Cohort in Edinburgh?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- All right.
So they looked at people from 1921 onwards
and it was fascinating.
They rated them for a bunch of things,
their age, their health,
attractiveness, facial symmetry.
- This is just based on the appearance
on the photograph by the way.
- Right.
- Like, no, you're not
meeting these people.
Were not taking any tasks,
we're just looking at their photos
and saying, "Are they healthy or not?
Are they old or not?"
- So what did they find?
- They found that if you
follow those people out
seven years from the time
that that photo was taken,
there was a really high
degree of predictability
that the people who were
rated as older looking,
whether or not they were actually older
chronologically or not,
if they were older looking,
they were more likely to die.
- Well, that totally fits
with what I hear from my friend,
Nir Barzilai in New York.
He's at the Albert Einstein
College of Medicine.
And he studies centenarians.
These are families, peoples
that tend to live over a hundred.
Not to be confused with centurions,
which are Roman soldiers.
Sometimes that's mixed up.
But what he sends me sometimes
are photos of his centenarians,
the father and the son.
And both those guys that
now imagining in my head
look really young.
Not just the guy that's a
hundred who probably looks 70,
but the 70 year old son looks 40.
And so this is fitting with the idea
that you are really as old as you look.
- When I read about the 2012 study,
I immediately thought,
"Oh, you know what would
be really interesting?
Is if now we could take those photos
and then test those
people's biological ages
with a DNA methylation clock.
- A Horvath clock.
- Horvath clock, which we
talked about in prior episodes.
And lo and behold, somebody
had already thought of this.
This often happens, by the way.
You and I are talking about research
and we like, "Oh, we
should check this out."
And then somebody else has done it.
But another team of researchers did do it.
And it turns out that it didn't correlate.
There wasn't correlation between
these people's appearances,
even though that was predictive
and their biological clock,
but there's a distinction
that needs to be made.
- Well, they were measuring
the blood clock in that case.
So what we've learned since
is that there are various
tissues have different clocks.
And it helps to have a specific clock
for that particular tissue.
Others have since gone
on to make skin clocks.
And they seem to work better
for measuring the age of the skin.
- And Mariana Boroni
who's a friend and colleague
of yours from Brazil.
She let a study that
was published in 2020,
showing that when you do this,
when you build this epigenetic clock
based on methylation of skin cells,
it does predict biological age quite well.
- It does.
And there's a good reason
why skin is going to age
probably faster than the rest of the body,
though it's still a good indicator.
And that is that it's
exposed the elements.
We know that if you grow up
in Australia, like I did,
that the UV light is
going to create DNA damage
that accelerates the epigenetic
changes that lead to aging.
So someone like me is going
to have probably older skin
than someone, my identical twin,
if they had moved to Norway.
- And like a third of Australians
suffer from some sort of,
is it skin cancer?
- Yeah. It's skin cancer.
It doesn't have to necessarily be lethal.
But a third of Australians
have something removed from their skin
that could be a tumor.
Now, what's been done since I was a kid
is that all beaches have free sunscreen,
which is great.
Not in my day where we
need to just sunbathe.
- Like when you show up to the
beach, there's like a little,
- Yeah. Yeah. The press pump.
Instead of having ketchup in the US,
they have sunscreen.
Well, now we have the hand sanitizer.
But it's the same thing, right?
It's like,
- Don't use that.
- So that's at the beaches?
- It is.
- You don't have to
bring your own sunscreen.
- No, no, no.
- That would save so much money.
Cause that sounds expensive.
- Billions of dollars in
healthcare costs in a country
for just a few dollars of sunscreen.
- That's a really great
investment actually.
- Yeah. Sometimes Australia
does things really well.
But the problem though is that,
for those of us who grew
up without the sunscreen,
we have this damage that
we are probably stuck with,
though increasingly we're learning
you might be able to
reverse that damage as well.
- And that was part of this
study by Mariana Boroni as well.
They looked at the
application of senolytic drugs
to these skin cells
and then measured the results.
- They did. So let's talk about skin aging
from a really modern perspective,
which is that skin is
full of senescent cells.
These are zombie-like cells
that reach a point where their
epigenome is so dysregulated
that they check out of the system,
they stop dividing.
- They're no longer producing.
- Right. They don't divide
and we can stain them blue
with a dye called beta-galactosidase.
And they're pretty common
in an older person.
The problem is that they secrete
these inflammatory factors
and also what are called
mitogens that stimulate cancer.
So they're not good things.
And in mouse and increasingly
in a few human studies,
we know that if you delete
these cells, kill 'em off,
you get rejuvenation of the body.
It includes internal organs,
you can treat diabetes with it.
But the skin becomes rejuvenated.
And in this study,
what they did was they took
out skin biopsies from people
and grew them in tissue culture
dishes, so it's ex vivo,
and they could then treat
them with senolytic drugs.
They used a couple, a pretty common ones.
One's called ABT-263
which is from Abbott's,
also known as Navitoclax.
And they also used rapamycin,
which we've talked about before
as a way of mimicking
starvation in the body
or fasting at least.
And what they found was
that those skin explants,
as they're called, grew thicker,
which is what you want if
you're reversing aging,
but they also could measure the clock.
They had a special skin clock
that they had built themselves
out of measuring the DNA
methylation chemical patterns
during aging of skin.
And there, they did find
that this senolytic treatment
reversed the age of those
little pieces of skin.
- The implications of
what you're talking about
in regards to the senescent
cells are really interesting.
Because again, what we're talking about
is the body's largest organ.
And it's not a system unto itself,
it interacts with all
of these other systems.
So if we have senescent cells
secreting these cytokines
all over the place.
They're not just staying in the skin,
they're going to move other places too.
So if you can lower the age of the skin,
you can save the rest of the body.
- That's exactly right.
And James Kirkland from the Mayo Clinic
has found that if you
just put what we call it,
what he called a dab of
senescent cells under the skin,
in a mouse,
it causes the whole mouse to get older.
So lowering the overall
burden of senescent cells
is a good thing.
And where are most
senescent cells in the body
because of the damage from UV light,
you get them mostly in the skin.
- Okay. So one of the ways
to do this potentially,
to fix this problem potentially
is retroactively,
we can address it with
some kind of senolytics.
We can also do it proactively
by just simply avoiding all that UV light,
wearing sunscreen.
Let's talk for a little bit
about what's actually happening.
How does UV light actually
like make ourselves go bonkers?
- Right. Well, the first
thing to appreciate is,
a little bit of sunlight
isn't going to hurt you.
In fact, you need it.
- Vitamin D.
- It's not bad for you.
But you can overwhelm the system.
So if you actually get
sunburn, you get red,
there's inflammation,
swelling of the skin, tenderness,
then you know you've overdone it.
And so what I tend to do is I
go out a little bit each day,
maybe for 10, 20 minutes,
get a bit of sun,
but not to the extent where
I'm going to get burnt.
And I always wear sunscreen out there
if I'm going to be out
for longer than that.
So what's happening actually
is that the sunlight is
hitting the DNA molecule itself
and causing two letters in the DNA,
two chemicals, the Ts.
Remember there's ACTG, four of them.
The Ts that are next to each
other will link chemically.
It's called a, a thymine-thymine dimer.
And now the cell,
- If the sun fuses them?
- The sunlight. Yeah, yeah.
Photon will hit them and
they'll become fused.
Like that.
[Matthew laughing] And so
if you've got a zipper,
you can imagine what's
happened to a zipper
that's fused along.
How do you possibly open up that zippers?
So you need to open up DNA
to read it and to copy it.
And now you've got these stuck together.
- So you can't. They
can't be opened up in it.
- Well, it's a big bulge in
the enzymes that read DNA,
have trouble getting over it.
So you have to remove them.
Usually what happens is
that the cell cuts them out
and puts new ones back in.
- Okay. And when you do,
when you kind of unfuse those,
do you know what happens?
You live long and prosper.
- That also helps. Hang on.
Let's see if I can do that.
There we go.
So what's actually happening though,
is not what you might think.
The old idea was that
these thymine diamonds
are actually mutagenic
and cause mutations.
But what we now know from
studies from my lab and others
is that the act of repairing that DNA
damages the problem.
And it's the reorganization
of the proteins in the cell
that ultimately lead to the
cell losing its identity.
- Okay. So I have not been
as good as you have been
about wearing sunscreen.
So I have to probably
address this retroactively.
Can I just like rub some
rapamycin and ABT-263 on my skin
and it's all good?
- It probably would work.
You have to be careful
cause rapamycin suppresses
the immune system, remember?
- Right.
- And right now,
those drugs are not
available, as far as I know,
for topical treatment.
But actually, Dr. Boroni,
then took that finding
and then use that little
skin explant beta-gal stain,
which is blue,
to look for peptides,
small little proteins that we talked about
in the last episode.
Which one of those 700 and
something peptides, if any,
had age reversal effects
got rid of that blue senescent stain
and reversed the clock?
And out of those 700
and something peptides,
she found a few.
There were about 20 that looked good.
And one of them she's
actually put into a product
that she sent me to try the other day.
It's called OneSkin.
And I'm not an advisor to
this group or anything,
but it did seem to work.
It looked just as good as retinae,
which is the leading product
that is used to reduce fine
lines and wrinkles too.
But I know she's developing
a additional peptides
to put into her cream,
not just this one that is
starting to show some efficacy
in human clinical trials.
- And the thought process
behind having a peptide
in a cream is what?
- So we don't know exactly
how this peptide makes the skin younger,
but one of the downstream effects,
one of the benefits certainly
is involving the COL1A1 gene
that makes the protein collagen,
which we've known for over 50 years
to be an important
component of younger skin,
making it more flexible and thicker.
- Collagen, of course,
is really super popular supplement
to put in beauty products right now.
It's a protein,
but it starts to attenuate
after our mid-twenties.
- Right.
When we're young,
it's the most abundant
protein in the body.
It holds together our bones and our skin.
- This is why babies are all chubby
and beautiful and plump, right?
- Yeah. It's a wonderful protein,
but we don't make enough
of it as we get older.
And that's why beauty
products in particular,
want to boost that production.
But you can also smear it on,
put it in powders, put it in drinks,
take it as a pill.
Energy drinks have it in it.
The question though is,
is it useful?
Is eating collagen going to be good?
Well, one thing I can say for sure
is that collagen is made
up of a lot of amino acids.
You're going to get the right
ratio of collagen amino acids
from those products
whether or not the collagen itself
makes it into your bloodstream
after being degraded in your stomach.
- By your stomach acids.
- Yeah.
There's a big debate
about whether these products are working
by being broken down and rebuilt.
Or actually make it into the body
as an intact peptide of
string of amino acids.
And I would say the jury's well and truly
still out on those things.
- It is fair to say
that as long as you pick
a safe collagen product,
there's likely not a lot of
harm that can come from it.
- Not at all.
There's no harm in taking collagen.
And probably what it's making sure
is that you don't have any deficiencies
in the amino acids you need
to make this most abundant
protein in the body.
- What we know right now
is that there's probably more benefit
from retinol or vitamin C in
terms of protecting your skin.
- Well, yeah. Vitamin C is
good for overall body's health.
It's essential as an antioxidant.
Retinae though is one of
the most important aspects
for preventing and reversing fine lines
and wrinkles in the skin.
- And these substance
actually create collagen
down the line, right?
- Right. These retinoids have
been shown for many years
to boost the production of collagen.
That's clear.
They also do other things.
They increase the growth of the epidermis
and the stratum corneum,
which are important parts of the skin,
make it thicker.
They also can actually lower
skin pigmentation by about 60%.
A lot of people want to
have even colored skin.
They make fibroblasts grow,
basically stimulating cell growth,
which is really important.
They lower the lipid.
So that's why it's often used
as a defense against acne.
And in fact, you were telling me earlier
that you've used that before.
- when I was a kid. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It dried out my skin
something awful though.
I mean, it makes you like
super susceptible to sunlight.
So you have to wear
sunscreen when you use it.
- Well, that's true today.
If you put it on your skin as an adult,
you have to be careful from the sun,
but mostly you end up with dry skin.
So you have to make
sure you're moisturizing
while you use the retinol products.
And there's another thing
that's important about these.
They are what are called MMPs,
this metalloproteinases
that break down the skin
and you want to inhibit those as well.
Which is what retinols do.
Actually, what they do is
they go inside the cell
and there's a receptor inside the cell
that binds to the chemical
that you're adding.
And they then go in and
turn on certain genes
that provide all of this extra cell growth
and other benefits to the skin.
But you have to be careful
because if you overdo it,
you get really dry skin.
And if you get it into
places like your eye,
it can be really unpleasant.
- Oh god, that sounds awful.
- Yeah, don't do that.
- They also have an
advantage of creating keratin
or promoting keratin?
- Right. So the keratinocytes
are lower down in the skin.
So keratin is a super
abundant molecule as well.
That's important, like
collagen, for the flexibility.
It's an important component
of not just your skin,
but your hair and your nails as well.
And your retinae can promote
the growth of the keratinocytes
that make keratin.
- Let's take a little aside
here and talk about nails.
Because this is sort of like,
you know, skin, hair, nails.
And a lot of people forget
that this is a pretty good,
or like a lot of people might not know
that this is a pretty good
indicator of your state of aging.
- Yeah. It's a pretty fun one.
I learned this a number of
years ago when I was at MIT,
that the rate of your nail growth
is a really good indicator of
how you're aging or not aging.
And so every time I have to cut my nails,
I'm thinking, how long
ago did I cut my nails?
It's all born from a study from 1979,
where they glued on these
little measuring tapes
onto people's nails
and measured them over years, in fact,
and there was one individual,
Mr.Bean actually,
who measured his nails
for most of his life.
- Like literally his name was Mr. Bean?
- Yeah.
- Like the,
- He might have been Dr. Bean
or Professor Bean, I'm not sure.
But we have that graph.
And actually, looking
at thousands of people,
we now know for sure that
the rate of nail growth
decreases about half a percent per year.
And if you measure that,
it's a really good indicator
of how old you are biologically.
I don't do that,
but I do pay attention
to whether my nails are slowing
down in their growth or not.
- I don't because I bite my nails,
which I know is a terrible habit,
but I like to say now that I'm
just engaging in autophagy,
which is, you know, good for my lifespan.
- Right. Taking that keratin
and putting it back in your stomach.
- Right. Exactly.
- But autophagy actually
is a function also
or a result also of retinae.
- It is. There's Ana Maria Cuervo
down at Albert Einstein
College of Medicine
is a world leader,
probably the world leader
in understanding autophagy,
the recycling of old proteins in the cell.
There's shallow autophagy
when you skip meals,
there's deep cleansing,
what's called
chaperone-mediated autophagy,
which is after three days of fasting,
these retinoic acids control
that pathway of autophagy
through a protein called LAMP2A.
What's exciting about Ana Maria's work
is just this year,
she published that if you
upregulate that mechanism,
this chaperone-mediated autophagy,
mice live a lot longer.
30, 40% longer.
So it's truly a longevity mechanism
that we can control with these retinoids.
- But there's something a
little bit counterintuitive here
because retinae actually
turns out to maybe not engage,
It's connection with the autophagy
isn't necessarily positive for lifespan
like we think in other cases.
- Right. As we keep
saying in these episodes,
there's a balance between
hunkering down during adversity,
and mimicking that and
going hell-for-leather,
burning the candle at both ends
with these abundance mimetics.
And it looks like retinoids, retinae
are the second type that they
stimulate the body to grow
because the body thinks
it's a time of abundance.
But it might be at the expense
of long-term skin health.
Because what it's also doing
is toning down, shutting down
this CMA, chaperone-mediated autophagy
that is shown, at least in animals,
to extend their lifespan.
- So retinae long-term bad
for the aging of our skin?
Jury is out?
- Unclear, unclear.
- Unclear.
- So what I would say as a scientist,
might work, though it needs to be tested,
is use retinols if you want
to reduce wrinkles and lines,
but not every day.
Give your body a rest.
Perhaps when you're fasting, don't use it.
And so you get that cleansing
in between the growth periods.
- Okay. So let's talk about one more thing
that everybody associates
with cleansing antioxidants.
But I know you're like,
at least in terms of
like oral antioxidants,
you're not a big fan.
You don't believe that they work
the same way that people think they work.
What about when they're in skin creams?
Cause you see that all the time.
Every skin cream's got like,
"Loaded with antioxidants."
- Right. So you said, what I believe.
Well often I don't use that term believe
because I'm a scientist
and I like to report
what's in the literature.
And what's in the
literature on antioxidants
is kind of depressing for longevity.
Over the last 30 years,
a lot of different
antioxidants have been tried.
Ingesting them, injecting them,
genetically modifying mice,
putting it on skin.
Very few results, if any.
There is one antioxidants
that seems to work
pretty well for longevity
and that's resveratrol.
But as you know,
I don't believe resveratrol
is working primarily
through its antioxidant activity.
Instead, it's activating
our body's defenses
and mimicking adversity.
- So there are topical creams
that have resveratrol in them now?
- There are an increasing
number of cosmetics
that have resveratrol in them.
But resveratrol is probably
not working primarily
through its antioxidant activity.
It's pretty weak as an antioxidant.
What's likely happening is
the resveratrol is turning
on the sirtuin activity,
which then turns on antioxidant enzymes,
but a lot of other good things,
revving up metabolism,
increasing blood flow,
getting oxygenation
into the tissue as well.
So I think that resveratrol
is a really great component of a cosmetic,
but not for the reasons
that you might think.
- Are there other NAD-boosting molecules
that are in skin creams right now?
- Well, I'm actually working on a way
to boost NAD in the skin.
That product's not
ready for primetime yet,
but already people have figured out
that if you boost NAD levels,
it's good for the skin.
Often you find nicotinamide
or nicotinic acid
or molecules related
to those in cosmetics.
And they've been shown
to actually have quite
beneficial effects on the skin.
Thickening, for example.
Mostly, people think it's
because of the B vitamin,
vitamin B3,
but actually, probably what's going on
is it's turning on again the
sirtuin defenses of the skin.
- There's one more molecule
we should talk about
as we're talking about topographic creams
before we move on to other remedies.
That's hyaluronic acids, HA.
These are really, really
popular right now.
- Well, yeah. They're really important
for the plumpness of the
skin and the ability to flex.
So when you do that,
this is collagen, but
it's also HA involved.
And it's not just in the skin,
HA is found throughout the body.
And what's super interesting about HA
is that it's found in abundance
in long-lived organisms.
It seems to be involved
in protecting animals,
in particular, from cancer.
One organism we've talked about
before is the naked mole rat
Actually, one of our children, Alex,
is handling and helping
to raise naked mole rats
up at the University of Rochester.
So I get photos of these naked mole rats.
They have beautiful skin by the way.
Nice and smooth.
I think we call them a
condom filled with walnuts?
- In an earlier episode,
we did refer to them as a
condom filled with walnuts,
which does not at least invoke in my mind,
a beautiful animal.
- But it's very smooth and supple.
- Beauty is subjective.
- Moving right along,
what's found is if you
take out these cells
from the naked mole rats,
and this is Vera Gorbunova's work
where Alex works in the lab.
Those cells,
they were found to produce
this jelly-like substance in the dish.
And when she looked at what it was,
it was hyaluronic acid.
And then she found out
that if you take away
that hyaluronic acid,
the cells will divide
and become more tumorigenic or cancerous.
Conversely, what she's
doing now is making a mouse
that has heaps of
hyaluronic acid in its body,
with the expectation and hope
that it will be resistant to cancer.
Long way of saying
that these products
aren't just for beauty,
they might actually be preventing cancer
in the skin as well.
- Your colleagues at
Harvard Medical School,
Kristina Liu and Janelle Nassim
have said that topical HA
does work really well as a moisturizer.
But they've suggested
that if the goal is to improve volume loss
and laxity of the skin,
that you might want to
consider an injectable HA,
does that make sense to you?
- Well, it does.
Cause HA is typically a
big chain of chemicals.
It's sugars put together
and they don't get into the skin
unless they're really small.
So one way of doing it is
injecting it into the actual skin.
But even then it's hard for
the cells to take it up.
So one other way that's in some cosmetics
is to have small chains of HA.
Oligomers, they're called,
to let them get into the skin
and then let the skin
synthesize those chains
inside the cell where they
belong and also outside.
That can be done naturally.
But also what we discovered
in patented in my lab
is that resveratrol boosts the HAS2 gene,
which makes the enzyme that
makes those strands of HA.
- David, a lot of things
we've discussed so far.
At first, they seem purely cosmetic,
but then when we've dive a little deeper,
we realized there were some
anti-aging implications.
So I didn't want to move on from skincare
until we talked about
what is probably the
most popular intervention
for wrinkles, for aging skin,
and talk about whether or not
there are any anti-aging
implications in Botox.
- Right. Well, besides retinol,
Botox is the most popular treatment.
And let's talk about what Botox is.
I think most people know,
but let's just remind everybody.
It's a toxin that comes from a bacterium,
clostridium botulinum.
It's found in foods.
If you eat it, a lot of it,
So you don't need much.
- You're about to lose 'em.
- Nanograms will kill you.
In fact, if you have, what is it?
A gram or kill a million people,
and 2 kilos can kill all of humanity.
It's that toxic.
- And we inject this into our faces?
- We do. And it's very effective
at getting rid of wrinkles.
There's no question.
The way it works is it
inhibits neurotransmission.
And neurons are telling the muscles in,
let's take my forehead, for example,
are pinching off the
muscles, they're tighten,
and you get the wrinkles.
So if you get Botox in there,
the muscles will relax.
And then the wrinkles will go
away for six to nine months.
You have to keep repeating it though
and keep getting injected in those spots.
- But this is not a clearing
out of cellular senescence
or REX, differentiation of cells.
This is just numbing the nerves.
- Right. It's purely
cosmetics, as far as we know.
It's not medical.
It's not treating headaches,
which it can be used for.
But that's okay.
If you look good, you're
going to feel better.
You're going to have a better social life.
All of that's good for longevity.
So it's still worth talking about.
- Okay. Let's talk about skin peels now.
Same thing? No real benefit?
I mean, it just make your skin look nice
and shiny and clean,
but no real benefit?
- I think this would be an area
of just getting things smoother,
not really changing the
age of the skin itself.
But there are some treatments
that probably cause enough
havoc and damage to the skin
to induce minor stress, adversity.
Hormesis, as we've called it.
And that would be microneedling.
So I've never had
microneedling done, have you?
- I mean, I've had tattoos.
Is that the same thing?
- Probably. With some bit of ink.
I mean, it sounds not too pleasant,
but this is a machine
that's putting thousands
of holes in your skin.
What's probably happening
is that there's a hormetic effect.
There's this release of
all sorts of repair factors
and could have long-term benefits
on the age of the skin as well.
But that certainly hasn't been proven yet.
- Almost everything
we've talked about today
has some cost involved.
And there are plenty of
questions still to be resolved
on a lot of these things.
But there's some stuff that,
you know, like I call it the no dust stuff
that really obvious stuff,
but we should probably say it anyway.
You mentioned earlier sun damage,
staying out of the sun's really important.
Smoking is really bad for your skin.
- That's probably the fastest way
to accelerate aging in your body.
And it shows up on your skin.
There's no question.
You can even see the difference in people.
- A lot of people don't know this,
but alcohol also shown in research
to be pretty bad for our skin.
So if you don't need,
- Right. I didn't know that.
I only recently gave up
alcohol having seen that study.
- And sort of like along those same lines,
smoking, alcohol, bad food,
eating processed foods,
eating foods that are rich
and fats and chemicals
and all that gross stuff.
- Yeah. It's amazing how
much your food can affect
the aging of your body and your skin.
And you can see the big difference
if you've ever had a pet
and you change the diet
of the dog, for example.
We see this in our mice.
We feed them good food,
and their skin and their
hair changes radically.
- And that's the important
transition point there.
The hair also changes as well.
What's good for your skin
generally is good for your hair too.
Let's talk about hair loss.
We're also going to
talk about hair graying.
Look, I started going bald
when I was in my mid-twenties.
I was told to blame my
mother's side of the family.
Is there any truth to
that, genetically speaking?
- Well, there's a little
bit of truth to that.
There are over 600 genes that
are involved in hair loss.
And only about 20 of them are
found on the X chromosome,
which is what you get from your mother.
Which accounts for about
a 11% of male pattern.
Baldness is what we're talking about here.
If you're a female it's 50/50,
whether it comes from your
father or your mother,
because these genes are
carried on the X chromosome.
So yeah, I mean, a little bit
you can blame your mother's side,
but most of it is fairly
random with your parents.
But there's a strong genetic component.
No question.
It can be slightly slowed
with these treatments
and modifications to your aging rate.
But ultimately in this case,
it's genetically determined.
That said,
no one's ever died from
hell loss or hair growing.
So it's not such a big issue.
- And actually it could be
dangerous to have long hair
in some instances.
- Well, yeah. Even in my lab,
if you have really long hair,
and you look into a centrifuge,
it can be quite a mess afterwards.
- Also, for people who do a
lot of work with pyrotechnics,
long hair, bad idea,.
- Right. Says the guy who
lost his hair a while ago.
- Yes. I'm safe from that.
But am I aging faster than other people?
I mean, is that an indicator?
Again, I started losing my
hair really, really early.
Is that an indicator
that I was aging early?
- Not in this case.
We've evolved as primates,
as descendants of these
apes 6 million years ago
to show off our age particularly as men.
Because as we get gray, we lose our hair.
We become more dominant.
We seem to the rest of the tribe,
we used to,
that we were wiser and
we had more influence.
- We were stronger, we made
it through the other apes.
That's why we look old.
- Yeah. Well, think of
the silver back gorilla.
That's the dominant one, right?
Same with humans.
This was a sign that you
should be given respect.
Not so much these days in our society.
It's more about staying younger.
But in previous times,
even just going back a few hundred years,
being gray and distinguished
was a real bonus.
- Okay. Why, just a fundamental
level, does hair loss occur?
I mean, I understand the
evolutionary drivers,
but at a cellular level, what's going on?
- Well, it really goes back to stem cells.
These are the cells that
keep dividing asymmetrically,
giving rise to other cell types
and that they reside in the
bulge of the hair follicle.
And there are a variety of types.
There are some that are just there
to produce the keratin in the hair.
There are others that are there,
melanocytes to produce the color.
There's a new type of stem cell.
It's called the HAP,
the hair follicle-associated
pluripotent stem cell
that people have found you can now isolate
and turn into bone and muscle.
We don't know what
roles they exactly play,
but what happens,
what we think happens during aging,
and was only recently discovered
less than a few months ago,
is that the important stem
cells for hair regrowth
get kicked out of the hair follicle.
They get spat out, which was unexpected.
We thought that they died, but
they actually get expelled.
- This going to like shut
out like a little can then.
- Right. And there's a video of this
that I tweeted about at the time.
So what that means
is that you want to prevent
them getting expelled.
But also you want to maintain
their function as well,
which is all about
preserving their epigenome,
their ability to remember the
type of cell that they are.
More externally, what we've
known since the 1960s,
is that the he follicle
shrinks and get small,
cause in part by dihydrotestosterone.
And when that happens,
the hair becomes thinner and thinner
until it stops going through
what's called the Anagen Phase,
which is the hair growth phase.
As opposed to the other three phases,
which are called catagen,
telogen and exogen.
- And this is really what
a lot of the treatments
are aimed at preventing.
Let's talk about some of those.
There's topical treatments.
There's pills.
There's some other stuff.
But let's start with topical treatments.
These are creams that
you rub on your head.
Did these things work?
- Oh, they undoubtedly worked.
This is minoxidil also known as Rogaine.
It was first discovered in the 1960s
from a group that was trying
to lower blood pressure.
So what it does is it stimulates
nitric oxide production.
Nitric oxide is important in Viagra,
opens up the blood vessels.
And they put it into patients
and they found that they
got extra hair growth.
- And these were patients
who were dealing with high blood pressure
and their doctors
prescribed them their stuff.
And they came back the next week
and they're like, "What did you do to me?"
- Well, a few months later, yes.
Some of them got new hair.
And then in the 1980s,
it was formulated with an
oily substance called DMSO
to get it through the
skin layer in the scalp
and found that it actually
does slow down hair loss.
Mostly at the back of the head,
but also here.
Even though it's not
recommended here, it does work
if you apply it across
the whole top, like that.
- Retinae also works for promoting anagen?
- Yeah. That's a little known fact.
If you have some retinol cream, 0.5%,
you can rub it on your
skin to reduce wrinkles,
but you can also rub it
on the parts of your hair
that are thinning out
or you don't want to lose hair.
And especially in combination
with Rogaine, minoxidil.
It works quite effectively
to slow that aging process.
- Yeah. There's a study
that showed after a year,
if you combine tretinoin,
which is retinae,
with little bit of minoxidil,
it resulted in regrowth
in 66% of the people
after a year.
- Oh.
- That's a good result.
I mean, if you're trying to regrow hair,
that's a really good result.
- Yeah, it is.
- The problem with this stuff
is you've got to apply
it several times a day.
A lot of people don't like the
way it feels on their scalps.
- Yeah. It's an oily substance.
It doesn't look good, doesn't feel good.
So most people stop doing that regularly.
But there's an alternative
that doctors are recommending,
which is taking a pill.
- Propecia.
Also known as finasteride.
Finasteride, Propecia.
This is a once a day pill
that inhibits testosterone?
- Well, more specifically
dihydrotestosterone.
- DHT.
- Right. DHT is converted
by 5-alpha reductase.
It's an enzyme that's
found throughout the body.
Now, dihydrotestosterone
is important in the body.
It reduces fat.
It's good for the heart,
good for the mind.
It has some other downsides.
It actually helps your prostate grow
as you get older and you
need to go to the bathroom.
So the real question is,
what are the best levels
for optimal longevity?
And actually there was a study on that.
There was a study of 3,690 men
that found that the levels
of that hormone were optimal
if they were relatively low,
but within middle range of 9.8
to 15.8 nanomoles per liter.
And those were the men
that lived the longest.
- Which is interesting
that you're saying
there's an optimal level
because there has been some
studies also looking at,
for instance, eunuchs,
who don't have really hardly
any testosterone at all.
At least not any that's been
produced by their testes.
And they tend to live a
really, really long time.
So on the face of it,
you might think like,
"The less, the better."
- Well, yeah. the testes
are doing more than
putting up testosterone obviously.
And cutting off testicles
probably is affecting a lot of things,
including the brain, depression as well.
- Not by the way, a longevity
strategy that we advise.
- No, we don't recommend that.
Talk to your doctor first.
But what's amazing about eunuchs
is that they live on average
14 to 19 years longer
than regular men that have deep voices.
- That's better than veganism,
that's better than exercise.
Like when we wrote this book,
you told me that the number one thing
that you learned about living
longer was eating less.
- But
- I have to change that.
- those numbers suggest
there is actually something
else people could do.
- Right. Cut off your
balls, if you're a man.
- But don't do that.
- Don't do that.
But it's interesting
that eunuchs tend to
live a really long time
as do smaller people
so the excess of testosterone
and growth hormone in general
seems to be promoting an
abundance memetic, okay?
But what's really cool
about these eunuchs is that,
I looked up the numbers,
out of a bunch of eunuchs, 81 in total,
three of them became
centenarians, lived to a hundred,
which is unheard of in
the normal population.
Normally, the chance in the
US of reaching a hundred
is only 1 in 4,400 people.
- So it's one in 4,400.
And in the eunuchs, it was 1 in 30.
Greater than 1 in 30.
- Yeah, exactly. That's
a 130 times greater
than the background rate, the normal rate.
So clearly it works.
It's just not something
you'd want to live with
on a daily basis.
- This might extend your life.
Like it'll make your life
longer, but not better.
- Well, and if it doesn't work,
it'll just feel longer.
- This really relates
to one of the problems
with inhibited testosterone,
which is that it lowers sex drive.
That's a potential side
effect to Propecia?
- Yeah. There's a bunch,
including mood swings.
Well, you can be depressed
and breast tenderness as well.
- Yeah.
You really have to just
hate the idea of being bald
to go through or to subject
yourself to a lot of this stuff.
- Well, I disagree.
Because these are side effects
that are in a low number of people.
So you could try it if you
want to see how it affects you.
And if it's fine, then good to go.
But make sure you tell your doctor
if there's something else going on.
- There's another intervention that has,
as far as we can tell, almost
no side effects whatsoever.
It sounds super cheesy and futuristic,
fricking laser beams.
- Yeah. Laser beams.
I didn't think this was real.
It sounds crazy.
You shine light on your head
and your hair will grow again.
Come on.
But I looked into it
and it's actually been approved
by the FDA as a treatment.
There are combs that have red laser light,
and caps that you can wear.
These are typically treatments
for 10, 15 minutes a
day or every other day.
And they literally have been
proven, clinical trials,
to slow down hair loss,
as well as regrow some aspects
of hair in, not everybody,
but in the majority of people.
- And this is called LLLT?
- Low laser light therapy.
- Therapy. I think that's right.
And we're not quite sure how this works.
We know it works, we're
not quite sure how.
There's a leading theory
about mitochondria.
- Yeah.
Some people think it's due to heat.
I think that that's a bunch of BS.
What probably is happening
that makes sense to me
is we've heard about nitric oxide earlier
about opening up the arteries
and the blood vessels.
Nitric oxide also controls
mitochondrial function.
And that laser light
has been shown to dissociate
this nitric oxide enzyme from,
what we talked about
earlier in another episode,
the electron transport chain.
There are proteins that make the energy.
They're called the
electron transport chain.
There are five of those,
and they're made up of multiple proteins.
And number five gets
disrupted by laser light.
In fact, this nitric oxide, synthase,
which is a protein that
we mentioned earlier
for blood vessels, also plays a role here.
And the laser light
takes away that protein,
that nitric oxide, synthase moves away.
And now what you get is
a bunch of free radicals
in the mitochondrion,
which results in what
we call mitohormesis,
A little bit of what doesn't
kill your mitochondria
makes them stronger and multiply.
And probably that increase in energy
is what allows those stem cells
to stay young and rejuvenate.
- Like rejuvenating stem cells,
which means that all of these strategies
for addressing balding,
the creams, the pills,
the one that's actually having
potentially seems to be having
an actual anti-aging effect
is the fricking laser beams.
- It is funny the world we live in.
But it's beyond hair now
that it looks like
shining red laser light,
which can penetrate deeply into the skin,
even into the sub layers
can be beneficial on the entire body.
And this is why we're seeing
a huge increase in the sales
of saunas that have infrared
laser light as well.
- Let's talk about
platelet-rich plasma injection.
Another thing that's gaining popularity
for a variety of conditions.
A lot of athletes use these
to recuperate after sports injuries,
but people are increasingly using these
for hair loss as well.
- They are. It's a
platelet-rich plasma, PRP.
And what you get done
is you go into a clinic,
they'll take out your blood,
they'll spin out the cells,
take the platelet-rich plasma,
and inject it either into
your veins for longevity.
Or in most cases, put it into your scalp
in many different places with a needle.
They anesthetised it so
that you don't cry too much.
And what is probably happening
is that this plasma is filled
with a bunch of goodies.
Exosomes we've talked about before,
hormones, little peptides,
probably what are called VSELL,
very small embryonic like cells.
We're get to that in another episode.
This mixture of things
probably helps the stem
cells in the follicle
get rejuvenated, maybe even
turn back the clock on those.
But exactly what component
in there that's working?
We really have no idea.
- You know the point of
frustration in irony,
which is that blood banks
and hospitals systems
are trying to get people
to donate platelets,
for lifesaving research and therapies.
But one good way to get people
to get their platelets out of their body
is to tell 'em that they
can regrow their hair.
- Yeah, it's true.
There are a lot of people
who don't just care
about feeling good and living longer,
but also how good they look,
and are willing to spend
a lot of money on that.
- Is there an anti-aging pathway
involved in the PRP, do you think?
I mean, you noted these like
the exosomes and the peptides,
these are all things we
talked about last episode.
It sounds like potentially.
- Well, undoubtedly.
We know that when you
fuse the blood systems,
the circulatory systems of an
old mouse and a young mouse,
the young mouse makes the old
mouse rejuvenated and younger.
We don't know all the components in there.
There are some of them.
There's one called GDF15, for example,
but we don't of what's in this mixture
that promotes hair growth.
When it's found, it'll be purified
and probably be given as
a cream or an injectable.
But until then, it's
this messy PRP treatment.
- Before we move on
from balding to graying,
there's this sort of like hair thing
that a lot of people are
familiar with when they age
and that is it stops growing on your head,
it starts growing in other places.
You get in your nose.
Your eyebrow hair start to get long.
You get in your ears.
What's going on here?
- We don't really know
why hair starts growing
in the wrong places,
as annoying as it is.
Probably I think what's happening
is that we have this evolutionary program
where we used to be a lot hairier,
six to 10 million years ago.
And those stem cells are
still ready to grow thick hair
in our ears, on our nose,
wherever you don't want it to grow.
And that the changes in
the structure of the DNA,
what we call the epigenome,
is changing over time.
And that those regions
that are normally silent,
in the ears.
So you don't get hairy ears,
are unraveling as part
of the aging process.
- So these are parts
of ancient genetic code
that have been allowed to
escape from the histones,
and now they're readable by the cells.
- Right. And we become our
ancestors, unfortunately.
So shave or pluck that out for now.
What that means is we would predict
that if we can slow down aging
using the methods that
we've talked about in this
and other episodes,
we should also prevent that
process from happening,
or at least delay it
till much later in life.
- Would that be the case
with graying hair too?
- It could be.
Because graying is part of
not just a genetic program,
but can be accelerated
by things that are also known
to accelerate aging itself,
such as psychological stress.
- This is really interesting
because we know from some
fairly recent research
that stress plays a key.
I mean, it's always been sort of known,
"Oh, you're going to
make me go gray." Right?
My grandmother, "You're
going to make me go gray."
And I'll be like, "Grandma,
you're already gray."
But we've long known
that gray hair is associated with stress.
What's coming out now
is that it doesn't have to be permanent.
- It's been known for probably centuries
that you can have these
binary colored hairs,
where at the tip of the hair, it's dark.
And then it's gray in the middle,
and then dark again at the bottom.
And people have wondered
what the heck is going on.
And just recently in 2021,
a group of researchers
had a look at what was
happening in people's lives
during that gray hair growth period.
And they found that they were
remarkably stressful periods
of those people's lives
where they didn't stop working,
they didn't sleep, they
didn't go on a vacation.
And so I think it's very clear
that stress can induce gray hair,
a loss of color from the hair.
But what's also remarkable
about that finding
is that it proves that
gray hair is reversible.
- Which means that what
we're talking about here
is an epigenetic effect.
- Sure. I mean, anything that is genetic
is essentially irreversible.
So this is an epigenetic effect.
What I would imagine
is that after you've been
for many, many years,
it's going to be very
difficult to reverse that.
But in the early phases,
when you're getting this spattering
of gray and color, gray and color,
you are able to get those packages of DNA
back to where they were
when you were young
using some of the methods that
we're talking about today.
And we've talked about in other episodes.
- And this has to do with those stem cells
that produce pigment.
They're melanocytes?
- Yep.
- And these sit right
next to our hair shafts.
- They do. And they inject the color
as the keratin is being put
together into that hair shaft.
And the prevailing theory
as to why we get gray
is that these melanocytes die
through a process called apoptosis.
Hopefully that isn't true.
I think it's true for very late in life.
But what we're seeing in this new study
is that they become
dysfunctional before they die.
And that's a period that we have a chance
to recover their function
and prevent them from dying.
And there are a number of ways
that I could think of at least,
to reverse that and
prevent them from dying.
One way though,
would be to use some of
these adversity mimetics
to get that epigenome to reset.
- That's what some researchers
have done in mice, at least,
in a fairly recent study,
actually this year,
using a combination compound.
Including cyclosporine,
a minoxidil,
which is the cream that
we talked about earlier,
and then another pigment-promoting drug.
We dug into this a little today,
and got really excited by what we found.
- Yeah. Because the paper tries to obscure
what this actual chemical is.
This age-reversing and
pigment-promoting drug.
Turns out it's called tacrolimus,
which is a very similar
molecule to rapamycin
or also known as sirolimus,
which we've mentioned in earlier episodes
is one of the main drugs
that can extend lifespan
and inhibit this complex
of proteins called mTOR
that responds to fasting.
- And like cyclosporine,
it's an immunosuppressant.
Which means it's an adversity mimetics.
It's showing your cells
that times are not all
that great right now.
- Right. It's making
your stem cells freak out
that things are going to be rough.
And maybe we should be rejuvenate
and start growing a little better.
I just want to mention
this cyclosporine A,
it's really interesting.
You said it's an immunosuppressant.
It's used to prevent organ rejection.
In my lab, we found it also
rejuvenates mitochondria
through actually making sure what's called
the mitochondrial permeability
transition pore or MPTP
is preserved.
Long story short,
I think this combination of cyclosporin A
for mitochondrial activity,
minoxidil, which we talked
about, improved blood flow.
And this pigment-promoting drug,
which is basically an analog of rapamycin,
which simulate a fasting response,
is the triple combo for
hair repigmentation.
- This is not yet ready for human use.
Undoubtedly, there's probably somebody
trying this out in Hollywood.
But as of right now, this is
still sometime into the future.
- I think so.
You know, people are already
trying rapamycin as a drug,
10 milligrams every week or so.
This is only being done by a few people
under doctor supervision,
but I could imagine that
there will be products
made available to the
general public one day
that would definitely restore hair color.
It's not a miracle that this happens.
It's just science and we're
going to figure it out.
- And just like another one of those cases
where when we address an aging pathway,
we're addressing things
that are downstream
of that aging pathway.
And this really relates,
I think, really well to a general theme
of what we've been talking about
over the past few episodes,
which is probably the individual problems
that come with aging that
we talk about right now
are not the things that
need to be addressed
if we can hit aging
somewhere up to stream of those problems.
- Yeah. And another important point is
that when we learn how to
reverse aging in the skin
and rejuvenate the hair and
get it to produce more color,
those lessons can be
applied across the body.
Because all cells have a
fundamental root cause of aging
and the same defense pathways
against that process.
So for instance, rapamycin,
cyclosporine, minoxidil,
these could be used
perhaps in really low doses
and under clinical conditions,
tested to see if they
have rejuvenating effects
in other organs as well.
- So maybe right now,
we're trying to figure out
how to help people keep
their hair more colorful,
try to keep it in their scalp
rather than on the floor.
But sometime down the road,
we could be addressing things
that are far greater
importance to far more people.
- Right,
And we foresee a day in my
lab where you can take a pill,
maybe three pills,
and you'll not just get younger,
but your hair will regrow
and become dark again if you wanted to.
- So we've covered a lot today.
As always, if people want to go back,
they can use the show notes,
which are timestamped
to find the thing that
they want to talk about.
Just gimme a big picture here though,
of everything that we've talked about
and what's the big takeaway today?
- Well, the big takeaway
is that we're on the verge of
being able to reverse aging
in the body internally,
but also externally.
And that'll be a world where
people not just live longer,
but feel better about themselves as well.
We've talked about injectables,
edibles, smearables.
It's a lot of ways of getting
these molecules into the body.
Not just ingesting them,
but putting them on the surface
and getting them into the layers
where they needed to slow
down or reverse aging.
And there's a lot to talk about
about the future of
all of this development
and what we're going to be seeing
in the next 5 to 10 years as well,
which we'll cover in a later episode.
- At the top of the show,
I mentioned that I had
come into this topic
a little bit reluctantly.
I didn't think we really
needed to be spinning our time,
helping people.
- You thought it was a superficial topic.
- I did. I thought it
was a superficial topic
and I can admit when I'm wrong.
- Rarely, but yeah.
- Once in a while.
This isn't just about looking good.
This is part of the
progression of the things
that we've been talking about
throughout the course of this series.
None of this negates.
Also the importance of doing the exercise
and eating well,
and engaging the circuits in your body
that respond to adversity.
- Getting enough sleep, don't stress,
all of that stuff we talked about.
- All that stuff is important.
But then the outcome of that
is it can be that you look better.
That's okay.
- Right. So the moral of this episode is,
if you can keep yourself looking good
by doing the right things,
you'll probably end up living longer too.
If you're enjoying this podcast
and you'd like to support us,
please subscribe on YouTube,
Apple Podcasts and Spotify.
On Apple, you have the opportunity
to leave us up to a five star review.
Also, check out the sponsors
that we mentioned at the
start of the episode.
That's probably the best
way to support the show.
These sponsors not only make it possible
for us to get this show to you at no cost,
but they offer products and services
that we truly believe in.
And we think you'll benefit from trying.
We also have a Patreon account.
It's at patreon.com/davidsinclair.
There, you can support the
show at any level you'd like.
Thanks again for joining us
on this episode of the Lifespan Podcast.